does this sound familiar to you
[Applause]
that's mr krabs walking in spongebob
can't you just pretend to listen for
once in your life and notice how quickly
he's moving it's like it's almost like a
dance you know that's typical of cartoon
characters whose exaggerated movements
and behavior call for equally
exaggerated sound
for foley artists like monique or sauna
this is one of the fun challenges of
creating sound for animation and unlike
live action movies it starts
with nothing
for live action you have production
sound like what they recorded so you
could kind of like be like oh this is
what it sounds like but in animation
it's all up to you it's like your world
to create whatever you want take gir in
invader zoom a little robot who's shaped
like this
he looks hollow so
for his body i use this and then for his
legs they look like little cable legs
and this or his little feet
and i always had
that kettle next next to it so the metal
kind of resonate and you can kind of
hear his body
appa the giant mythical beast in avatar
the last airbender needed a bigger
rounder sound
because he's so big i have to try
different things for him first i tried
like a couple cushions to do like
massive
we tried like big like tree trunks and
hit them we couldn't really get how big
and fluffy he is as well what i did i
got a plunger i got some paper napkins
filled it up
so he kind of like took the hollowness
out of it and got a multiple pieces of
duct tape
when i played it it sounded good and i
tried one that was empty you could hear
the difference
the duct tape muted the sound taking
away any harshness so oppa sounds not
only big but also fluffy and round like
the cuddly creature he appears as on
screen
seem to know everything haha very funny
even if the characters are based on
actual real life animals the sounds
still get wackier in animation like the
sea creatures of spongebob
crabs has a couple things happening
think about the crab as a shelled so
steps
[Music]
like the sound of the crab movement
doesn't exactly sound like a real crab
does it
that's because real crabs don't move
like this
[Music]
this mile a minute pace isn't unique to
spongebob characters and animation
generally move faster and more
percussively than they do in live action
keeping up for foley artists can get
exhausting
that was good
to emphasize the force behind all these
swift jerky movements accent sounds take
on special importance especially for
fight scenes like the fast punches
monique did for this scene from the kung
fu panda tv show
or this popping sound
[Music]
anytime we have a chance to add sound to
a scene we do like when they're fighting
anytime when you see those little white
lines that go like that
i'll add a wish to it i like using
bamboo sticks you could use antennas
or anything that does this kind of sound
sauna would also accent the character's
fight moves with what's called a shing
[Music]
i use like a shovel so there's like a
deeper kind of shame
also you gotta be careful how to hold
the shovel like you can mute it
you could make it more ringy
i've used a machete in the shovel
and then
i've used this thing it's not sharp at
all with this
[Music]
that was beautiful
these as with most foley sounds are
often combined with sound effects added
digitally by sound designers so they
could get mine manipulated or have
theirs fully and effects together just
really
fill it up and make it sound great
this combination of foley and digital
effects is key especially because there
isn't any production sound to begin with
it's up to the foley artist to fill this
empty playground with sounds each
created individually and often layered
together on spongebob for example the
foley artists would do something called
a water pass
we would take a big tupperware tub and
fill it up until it was about this much
from the top and we would
do a movement instead of cloth
we would move water
so we did all of the props dry because
if we made any of the props sound wet it
would be redundant with the water but
foley artists aren't afraid to get wet
or go over the top especially when
creating sounds for slapstick humor and
animated comedy sauna used an extra wet
chamois to amplify the mud splats and
rugrats
and capture the spirit of the messy
babies
[Music]
she also used a chamois for the kids
eating sounds which again had to be
exaggerated to match the exaggerated
visuals so whenever we had rugrats
eating again animation make it bigger
than life you know over the top
so for that slurping
gee they must be really hungry i'm gonna
do an element
of chamois and i'm gonna do a bowl like
a drinking out of all
gee they must be really hungry all kinds
of mouth sounds tend to get heightened
in animation like appa with his gooey
tongue lick we want to get something
nice and juicy and wet
[Music]
and this scene in teen titans
wider i need to get both my hands in
there
that's one
wider
there we go
okay she's sticking her hand
in his mouth we're gonna layer the sound
of
me using my mouth
and then we're gonna layer it with
something else that sounds cavernous and
open which is this glove
you know it sounds
like it's got like some depth to it it's
not like shallow
now let's see
so the mouth sounds get wetter
the movements get faster
and even something as mundane as
footsteps gets played up for dramatic
effect
nearly every sound gets heightened in
animation which means the creative
possibilities for foley artists are
pretty much endless
[Music]